[Music]
How to Train Your Dragon because you
know you've always wanted to okay so the
TV commercials for this movie have
praised it as being like one of the most
timeless movies since ET and I don't
really know about that but after seeing
the movie I can kind of see why I got
that comparison like in et it can't be
friends something that he probably
shouldn't that would be a dragon a
dragon that looks remarkably like stitch
from Lilo & Stitch then I found out that
the writers of lilo & stitch wrote How
to Train Your Dragon and it all made
sense yeah they loved that creature
design the movie is set in a Viking town
where the Vikings are nice people in
this movie and they do one thing and
they do it very well till Dragons the
black sheep of the community is hiccup
voiced by Jay Baruchel I hope that's how
you pronounce his name who plays the
same character in the 3d CGI dragon
world that he plays in every other
live-action movie he's ever been in but
what can you say he's good at it but
then hiccup meets up with and slowly
befriends a dragon that he calls
toothless and then the kind of ETS
storyline ensues now I actually really
liked this movie I had a good time with
it and there were some moments that I
just straight-up felt like a kid again
I'm getting soft now in my opinion I
think you have to see this movie in 3d
it was clearly made for 3d and I can't
imagine seeing some of those flight
sequences in 2d this movie in 2d would
kind of seem like decaf coffee like why
bother now the very beginning in this
movie was really exciting and then it
kind of slows down while he's
befriending and playing with his lizard
dragon now this movie does have some
sweet action some really good
cinematography but it doesn't actually
revolve around it so if your ATV is just
ravenous for some hardcore CGI
cinematography just thrown on the screen
for an hour and a half you might leave
this movie disappointed it's really a
movie about a kid whose dragon although
it does have some sweet action in this
movie also features the voices of
ginnifer who were all great in the movie
but the end action sequence in this
movie was absolutely badass I mean it
gives movies live-action and not just a
straight-up run for its money as far as
family movies go it's a hundred times
better than any of the others out right
now namely the one yeah so I personally
loved it check it out take the kids and
click on the link in the sidebar to see
more not necessarily in that order
yeah I slipped that in there check it
out it was cool
[Music]